everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're gonna be
starting a new series i had a lot of
requests for people to go through the
famous games on my website and give
commentary on them so for those are that
are familiar with the website the chess
website calm the famous game section i'm
going to start with the old games so if
you want to follow along and know which
games are coming up but i'm just gonna
go through the list and just start
giving my commentary on each of the
famous game so the first game that we're
gonna talk about today is a non verse
joel lo da and as many of you know anon
is the world chess champion right now
he's probably a lot more known than joel
lot lo da but lo da is a french GM he's
a very very strong player and he's also
one of the three players to have beaten
every world champion since 1975 which is
a pretty amazing feat if you think about
it there's some amazingly strong players
that he's beaten so with with that I'm
not gonna tell you who won I will tell
you that an on is playing the white
pieces and lo da is playing the black
pieces I don't want you to go in to any
of these games that I give a commentary
on and say because you know black lost
or because white lost all their moves
are incorrect that's usually not the
case it's usually one side just at one
point or another and I'll talk about
that during the match makes a move that
was just a phenomenal move or the other
the other side just strategically or
positionally didn't make the best move
at one particular spot but the rest of
his game could be completely fine so
just think about that going through and
as many of you know a lot of the famous
games are main are known famous because
of one particular combination or
sacrifice and so right before that that
happens in each of these games I'm going
to discuss I'm gonna go ahead and pause
it and see if you can find that move
yourself so without further ado I'm
going to go ahead and get into the game
and give my commentary
for it game starts with pawn to e4
followed by pawn defy this is the
Scandinavian defense for those familiar
with this game to name in defense pawns
going to capture on d5 and black is
going to capture on d5 with this Queen
already bringing this Queen to the
action which it top level you don't see
that often but in the Scandinavian
defense you almost always will
White's gonna continue with Knight to c3
simple development move for Knight
bringing out a minor piece and at the
same time attacking the center and
forcing the Queen to move his major
piece his Queen here to move twice so
the Queen's gonna come to a5 standard
move from black getting his Queen out of
harm's way at the same time once white
moves his pawn his deep on here which he
will very soon he's gonna be pinning
down this Knight to the King so this is
a common theme that you'll see in the
Scandinavian defense as far as bringing
the Queen to the a5 Square from here why
it's gonna continue bringing his pawn to
d4 kind of as we just talked about and
Black's going to continue his
development move with his minor piece
with Knight to f6 simple development
move at the same time attacking these
light squares on d5 and E for whites
going to continue with his develope move
Knight to f3 same theme here he's trying
to attack the dark squares here as you
can already see both sides are just
developing their their Knights trying to
attack the center the next move my black
is pawn to c6 now a lot of times people
will try to get their bishops into the
action but black looked at this and he
saw that if Bishop came to g4 most times
the top GM level you're not gonna see
this Bishop actually sacrifice in
exchange this night here on f3 so white
could just bring his pawn to h3 and he
would kick his Bishop back to h5 and
after pawn to g4 black would come to g6
and so I guess then lo da looked at this
position and said you know what I just
really don't want to bring my Bishop
here to g6 so instead of playing the
very common
to g4 instead he played pawn to c6 and
this is very common a lot of times when
you see players that like the ComicCon
pawn structure and this is exactly what
that is they they normally bring their
pawn to c6 and then later on they'll
bring their other pawn to e6 and it's
many of you know from Kyle Kahn anytime
you have your pawns on c6 and East six
you normally want to get your
LightSquared Bishop out first then bring
your pawn to e6 and then later you're
gonna bring your Knight to d7 common
theme that anytime you you start to see
a opening develop at the top GM level
you can pretty much guess some of the
moves that you'll see later on so from
here White's going to continue with his
own play he's gonna bring his Bishop to
c4 this is a very aggressive move at the
same time he wants to get his
LightSquared Bishop out and attacking
this f7 Square which is a huge weakness
for black at the early stages of the
game since his King is very vulnerable
here at the same time he wants to clear
away if he wants to castle on the Kings
side it's it's still up for debate if
he's going to castle on the Kings side
it really depends on what black does but
most times white will try to get his
lights his LightSquared Bishop out and
at the same time they'll try to get his
knight to this f3 square so that if he
wants to he can castle on the King side
from here Black's going to respond by
bringing his Bishop to f5 simple
development move also he wants to get
his LightSquared Bishop out again so
that he can bring his pawn to e6 so that
if he wants to he can castle on the
Queen side a lot of times in this comic
on a lot of players will castle on the
Queen side also another move going back
a few moves the the c6 move another good
reason this is done there's a lot of
times people want to have a place for
their Queen to go so you can see here
that their Queen may become vulnerable
later on it's not right now but if they
ever wanted to now they have this dark
diagonal that the Queen can come to so
just another move a lot of times GM
players will make a move and have many
reasons why they did it so that may be
another reason
while Oda did this when he moved his
pawn to c6 from here White's gonna play
Knight to e5 now he did have a few
options here he didn't have to bring his
Knight to e5 so if you guys following
along or trying to figure out what you
would have done it would have been
completely fine if he would have castled
on the kingside this is a completely
fine play but he decided to to be
aggressive and attack this pawn on f7 so
he went ahead and brought his Knight to
e5 here and if any of y'all have watched
my other videos I've always said don't
bring your minor piece move it twice if
you don't have to so in this case you
can pretty much note that that anon has
a very specific plan that he wants to
employ here because no GM player no top
player is gonna bring their knight and
move it twice without having a very good
reason
so from here black really doesn't have a
lot of moves that he can make that are
very good he definitely does not want to
bring his bishop back to g6 because
white would jump all over this and
exchange a knight for a bishop this
early on in the game so really his best
move here is to bring his pawn to e6
blocking off this bishop from the f7
pawn now from here anon really starts to
attack as you can tell here once you
start to be aggressive you really don't
want to become passive because if you do
then you really just lost momentum so
what if not most really thinking when
you play this Knight to e5 after he saw
e6 he now brought his pawn to g4 knowing
that it can't be taken right now because
his Queens covering it and the bishop is
gonna have to retreat and once it does
retreat the pawns gonna start pushing up
to h4 now already we can tell that more
than likely the King if you wanted to
cast well now he can still castle on the
King side but if you wanted to castle
you could cast on the Queen side or he
just may opt not to Castle entirely but
what we can tell from here is he's gonna
start to push these ponds
up to the Kings side so
what love ei was probably thinking is
you know right now I'm not being
attacked so the first thing I need to do
is I need to get some King safety I need
to go ahead and get this Knight out of
here get him into the action get as many
minor pieces as I can into the action at
the same time if I need to I can castle
on the Queen side so lady Lodi I decided
to bring his Knight to d7 again this is
a common theme anytime you have your
pawn on c6 and East six you normally
want to bring your Knight to d7 you'll
see this pretty much anytime in the
CARICOM and from here
white decided to go ahead and in
exchange Knights
so this Knight that was here is going to
come to d7 and then White's gonna start
pushing up the board on h5 really
there's not many places for black to go
here but he did bring his Bishop down to
e4 now White had two options here and
when I looked at it I personally would
have opted for castling kingside and
again yes you can Castle kingside if the
King is not attacked even if the rook is
attacked you can castle button on
instead decided to bring his rook to h3
later on we'll see that he wanted to
bring his rook to e3 and he noticed that
if he cancelled on the King side it
would take him two moves to get his
knight here which if he brought it to h3
first then he could get there a lot
faster so anytime you can save a move
and you have a very specific plan
especially at the top play go ahead and
do it now from here this is a question
we'll move from low DA as we can see
later on but he brought his bishop to g2
now personally I think he should have
brought his bishop back to d5 and just
started exchanging pieces off here but
instead he got a little greedy
overextended his Bishop and he brought
his bishop to g2